good morning
we're ready to start the meeting um and
i will give you confirmation
once we've confirmed we're live
streaming to youtube
beth i can confirm i can see it on um
live streaming
thank you uh we've now had confirmation
that we're live streaming and i hand
over to councillor cox as chair to start
the meeting
hey garage good morning and welcome
good morning and welcome to welcome
counselors and officers thank you very
much indeed
uh for attending today um can i ask are
there any apologies for absence today
uh yes apologies from councils clarence
hocking and evans
um are there any declarations of
interest
hmm
uh
chair are you still there are you having
any technical difficulties
i think we'll just wait a moment um for
the chair to come back
i'm not sure if he's having technical
difficulties today
didn't he have technical difficulties
last time
jerry there
counselor austin would you like to take
over as vice chair please
i think we're having some technical
difficulties
sorry sorry cats austin we can't hear
you
i was muted with everybody else i think
right
hope we've had the item one apologist so
minutes of the last meeting are we happy
to approve those or
are there any comments
could somebody propose them as exposed
vice chair and somebody second please
are you all in favor of the minutes
as drafted thank you very much
um are there any declarations of
interest
okay um item four is exclusion of the
press i don't think that's relevant to
this minute this meeting
so we get to item five licensing act
2003.
i take it murray that's a presentation
of some sort is it
yes chair um it will be andrea as the
licensing manager who will be addressing
you
right so can we proceed with that now
please
good morning we're here this morning to
consider the representations that have
been received
following the consultation of the review
of the statement of licensing policy
this took place
between the 27th of july 2020 and the
16th of october 2020.
as stated in my report before comment
consult consultation commenced the
policy had to
undergo some amendments to meet the
accessibility requirements for documents
that go onto the website
however this affects the layout and did
not not change
any of the content of the document
we received full requests for a hard
copy of the policy to be sent
out in total we received seven
representations of which four were
no comments to make and also two
comments
one from legal and one from licensing
ourselves
setting out some administrative changes
appendix a is policy taken into
consideration
the proposed changes based on the
representations received
these are indicated in red
appendix b sets out a table of those
representations
with those proposed recommendations
chair and committee are asked to
recommend the approval of the policy
as amended to full council
thank you that's the end of your report
thank you
are there any questions please
answer hayes thank you chair
uh just clarification on item
2.3 on page 20
of the policy which i believe may
have a wrong date on it i just need
clarification on that
it states that this policy was formally
adopted by the council
on the 23rd of november 2020
that's a past tense description with a
forward date so i just need that
clarifying please
yes that that would just be the date
that full
council is the date of the full council
where the actual policy would be
approved so
that's the date that's been put in there
shouldn't it be um not was there's a
past tense
well when the policy well yeah yes
i know i just don't think much but sorry
no no no that's
fine sorry what section was that again
which number
2.3 on page 20
that's what i've got on my policy
yep i can amend that that's fine that's
not a problem
thank you thank you for that
counselor carlswell did you have a
question
no i didn't no you didn't are there any
other questions or comments please
do we need to uh accept the report as as
presented
chair councillor rotherson
thank you chad i don't want to let this
great piece of work just pass
uh unrewarded i think it's very sound
it's very good
it builds nicely on the draft that we
saw i thought the consultation was
thorough and i'm reminded that when we
sat in the
audit scrutiny committee we saw that the
annual auditor ombudsman's report
investigated only five complaints
against the council
and none of those were upheld we had an
excellent record
and that kind of outcome is dependent on
these very sound foundations that we see
today so
thank you very much officers for this
piece of work thank you
are there any other comments please if
you're
happy then we will proceed twice item
six on the agenda which is the
uh license for the vehicle fp10khw
uh this vehicle is 10 years old and then
sorry can i just interrupt
yes sorry can i just interrupt uh we
will need to just take a a roll call
vote on
on that agenda item on the full policy
please
oh really oh i'm sorry i think um do we
have a proposal
sure i propose gabriel rollerson thank
you and council
please thank you i'll just run on earth
for a roll call vote
now okay uh so councillor austin
favor councillor bradford
councillor bradford
four thank you councillor hayes
councillor as well
councillor natalie four
councillor rolison
councillor rolison sorry four
councillor russell or
councillor cox so yes i'm back um
i have read the policy i think it's a
really good policy so i'd say in favor
but i'd also add that we perhaps um
recall our thanks to the officers for
doing this as council robinson said
it's it's it's a very good piece of work
and
uh it's shown in that we have had no
complaints upheld against us by the
local government's ombudsman
so i think it's uh we do we should
record in a minute i think our thanks to
the officers for creating this document
that's noted um that's unanimously
passed then
thank you um with the chairman like to
take over for the item six on the agenda
and how it is returned to us you're
doing such a wonderful job beryl but if
you don't mind i will if that's all
right
uh so have we gone into part two i'm
sorry
it's an item
this part of the agenda sorry so item
have i got the right agenda here
councilman cox is now going to take over
exactly
yes sorry um the recommendation is
that under section 104 of the local
government act 1972 the present public
be excluded from the meeting of the of
the particular
items on the on the grounds that it
involves the likely disclosure exempt
information as defined
on the relevant paragraph of what part
one of schedule 12a of the act
um i so propose could would someone
second that please for me
sorry we sorry to interrupt we don't
need to go into part two at the moment
um we're just going to be um the license
manager will just run through the report
on the uh taxi extension righty ho um
and then we will adjourn to discuss
after that right so
can i can i just interrupt can we just
check that you you are working from the
correct agenda chairman
because there's no part two we're
looking at um item six of today's agenda
the request for a hackney carriage
vehicle extension
yes i've got that but i've got part two
on my my notes here for some reason um
there's no need for us to move into part
two for uh in respect of this
item righty ho sorry about that it is it
is down on the
for some reason on that agenda sorry
anyway okay
the papers i've got anyway sorry so i
apologize for that but yes can we move
on to
um could we have the report from the
officer please
thank you so the next item is
to consider a bit one vehicle extension
the request is from mr pete shapley for
a grey ford
s-max which is now 10 years and five
months of age
since the committee report was published
the vehicle has passed its mot
on the 27th of october with two
advisories
which are suspension arm pin or bush
worn but not to result in an excessive
movement nearside and offside and a
brake
disc worn pitted not scored but not
seriously weakened
the vehicle was viewed by a licensed
officer on the 13th of october
and photos have been included with the
report
the vehicle passed its depot inspection
on the 29th of october
the applicant unfortunately is unable to
attend
but has asked that i relay the following
statement
we hope an extension may be granted by
yourselves on this vehicle
you will find the usual wear and tear
for its age but the car is very clean
and tidy
it is well maintained and serviced by us
at our own garage
dolbies it is a one driver vehicle
and not overused by several other
drivers
we hope that in this turbulent time and
with the impact these times are having
on the current climate
causing for more tightening of finances
by businesses
business owners and self-employed
employers
try to keep the employed working times
are hard
we hope you will grant us the ability to
continue using
the vehicle and the driver driving
chairman committee are asked to
determine this request
thank you
thank you very much indeed i think we
need to go into private session now to
determine this
are there any photographs of this
vehicle at all
it should be with the report all right
yeah
i thought about the screen
could you please remind me of the
advisories please
again these are suspension arm pin
or bush worn but not resulting
in excessive movement near side and
offside
and brake disc worn pitted
not scored but not seriously weakened
thank you
and the vehicle is 10 year over 10 years
old
ten years and five months yeah
german can i say that
there are pictures of the vehicles which
show it to be
in quite a reasonable situation i do
find
having you know been to lots of these
inspections before
that one of the important things about
the condition of the vehicle
is whether it smells fresh and clean
unfortunately
in a position to judge that at the
moment we're not going to do a sniff
test we've got
the license perhaps for the six months
review
um to make sure that it hasn't
deteriorated further
i'm happy to propose that i suspect
that's something we probably need to do
when we go into private session
um but it's there on the table and i'm
sure that it will be seconded
um are there any other questions in
questions of the licensing officer
um from any members
can i ask the advice the advisories has
the
has the uh owner indicated they're going
to have those
sorted out within a with a time frame
we've not we've not been indicated that
that is something that
could be conditional that it's done
within a time scale yeah and also
regarding this
regarding the smell i'm sure the officer
that inspected the vehicle
would have made note that it had a an
onc if it did
happen could we perhaps have a sniff a
sniff test
in the future i think but i think what
what council rum
uh barrel austin says is actually quite
true is it's a single driver and if it
looks
good you tend to think vehicles that are
looked after tend to be looked after
mechanically as well as um
inside so that that's also the good i
think in this particular case
um if there are no more questions that
people used to ask you
oh sorry council russell yeah well i i
just noticed that um
it's maintained by their own garage door
beers
and i know they're not marking their own
homework here because it has to be
inspected
it has to be inspected also for the
mot's
uh they sound very sensible people and
and very caring
too of their staff so i'm quite happy to
second
councillor austin's proposal
um do we do we need to go into private
session and we have a proposal i think
do people are happy people are happy
with that the only thing i would
possibly add is that the
advisories are uh dealt with within six
months would that be a reasonable
amount um part would the
proposer and seconder accept that as a
part of the um
the approval but within six months the
advisories are dealt with
oh yes councillor hayes has got his hand
up so sorry councillor hayes
yeah i think we do need to go into
private session on this one um oh right
helen
okay can i ask that we then go into
private session
trish could you um stop the live
streaming it's
it's sarah democratic so oh sorry i will
start the live stream and i'll let you
know when it's stopped live streaming
thanks very much indeed but we have